dernier volet ce soir de notre grande
enquête sur le coût de sur le coup de
foudre touristique des anglais pour
notre région
après les raisons de cet engouement
l'attrait gastronomique et l'image de la
région
ce soir les britishs à la neige ou
pourquoi les anglais préfèrent les
pentes pyrénéennes au monde écossais
suit donc et fin du reportage d'hélène
airlink scène et céline faye
mais sa venue pour la neige et pour le
système d'achat
non bien moi que dans les alpes mais
aussi une photo de moi sous les 6 je la
mènerai à l'angleterre pour la rentrée à
lausanne il ne croyait pas que j'aurais
une nouvelle chance et risque au delà
suis très fier d'y faire du costa rica
odinga tabaski ceux-là super inez je
n'ai pas trop connu deux filles je les
trouve super s y croire
dix mille anglais viennent tous les ors
en midi pyrénées pendant l'hiver pour
faire du skull la famille young par
exemple vient du milieu le sexe ils sont
restés deux semaines à barèges et nous
avons suivi pendant leurs derniers jours
merci beaucoup
les anglais sont des beau client
on n'a vraiment pas pour le vainqueur ce
sera en partie inchangé au matériel
si vraiment tu vu qui est très content
ils nous achètent les produits notamment
le veine il aime ça les fromages du pays
et de des produits en prémice cambrésis
surtout quand ils s'en vont il importe
de nos produits régionaux quoi ce bail
en angleterre des vins populaire
français mais alors comme des pires que
la france est en tête encore un couscous
les banlieues se déplacent le plus
souvent en groupe
en plus des lignes régulières 4 charter
viennent toutes les semaines
rempli de futurs skieurs sur place ils
continuent parfois la ville de groupe et
choisissent l'hébergement en commun le
plus économique comme ici dans cette
maison entièrement loués pour eux par
une agence de voyages anglaise la fin de
chaque groupe est différent
certains viennent ils ont entendu parler
des stations et des cours de ski et puis
il ya des siens celui qui les
intéressent d'autres viennent de sa vie
parce que c'est la façon la plus
économique mais toujours à la fin du
séjour ils sont ravis d'avoir fait leur
entrée en contact avec les français et
d'avoir parler français mais c'est quand
même l'hôtel le mode d'hébergement le
plus courant qu'à la moitié des
touristes anglais le choisissent ils
représentent 40 % de la totalité de
l'hôtel c'est une clientèle très
intéressant parce qu'elle vient à noël
c'était difficile à remplir
elle remplit tout le mois de janvier et
tout le moins toute la fin du mois de
mars
pas de montagne fallu station les
anglais pour skier doivent donc quitter
leur pays
à londres l'office pensée du tourisme le
sait et en profite pour faire une large
publicité sur les montagnes françaises
et leurs équipements comme dans les
pyrénées
nous faisons un effort
pour faire reconnaître dynamiser
effectivement le ski à midi pyrénées
nous avons des journalistes qui viennent
juste de rentrer donc des hautes
pyrénées
nous comptons faire un accueil le mois
prochain dans la haute-garonne donc sur
le champ nous faisons ce que nous
pouvons pour essayer donc de faire
accroître ses prêts clientèle anglais
sur sur midi pyrénées
m
soleil accueille montagne station bien
aménager les pyrénées en tout pour
plaire aux anglais seulement voilà dans
leur tête les pyrénées sont le plus
souvent espagnol donc une image de
marque à modifier et puis leur séjour
sont trop courts en moyenne cinq jours
l'idéal serait de les ramener au moins à
une semaine voire deux là aussi c'est
encore à nous de jouer